hay tensión entre los trabajadores de
general motors y los trabajadores que
están en la planta de mexico los
detalles los tienes daniela blandón
daniela gracias por estar con nosotros
hoy cuéntenos que lo que está sucediendo
allí hola santiago mire cerca de 6500
trabajadores de una de las plantas de la
multinacional estadounidense general
motors en méxico están en votaciones
este martes y miércoles sobre la
posibilidad de destituir a su sindicato
llamado miguel trujillo lópez al que
acusan de defender los intereses de esta
corporación
eeuu ha expresado preocupación por los
conflictos laborales en la planta de
general motors en la ciudad de silao en
guanajuato más aún después de un año de
que entrará en vigencia del tratado de
libre comercio entre estados unidos
méxico y canadá en abril hubo una
votación que fue cuestionada por
washington y ahora se está repitiendo
esa votación
tenemos un nuevo acuerdo comercial
el tema que a diferencia del tratado de
libre comercio firmado en 1994 en esta
ocasión pone de manifiesto el tema
laboral
como centro de discusión el evitar que
se vulneren los derechos de los
trabajadores ha abierto la posibilidad a
que las empresas en acuerdo con el
sindicalismo antidemocrático no vulnere
los derechos de los trabajadores también
la seguimos hablando de trabajadores
porque el reino unido está buscando
empleados sin santiago pues las vacantes
de empleo en ese país se dispararon en
julio a su máximo histórico según cifras
oficiales a medida que se va pues
reabriendo la economía el número de
puestos sin ocupar veamos es de casi un
millón es decir casi cinco veces más de
lo que se registraba antes de la
pandemia que eran 168 mil al mismo
tiempo el departamento de estadística
reveló que el número de empleados en las
empresas asciende a unos 28,9 millones
muy cerca de los niveles pre pandémicos
aunque sigue estando por debajo por
200.000 por debajo de lo que había
seguimos hablando de cifras y hablamos
de la economía colombiana cómo está la
economía del país cafetero el producto
interno bruto de este país tuvo una
contracción del 2,4 por ciento en el
segundo trimestre de este año si se
compara con el primer trimestre porque
pues el departamento de estadísticas
dice que esto ocurre debido a las
protestas antigubernamentales que
mantuvieron bloqueadas ciertas vías
principales durante varias semanas el
repunte interanual de la economía
colombiana qué quiere decir frente al
mismo período del año pasado fue del
17,6 por ciento pero no hay que hacerse
muchas ilusiones santiago porque pues el
presidente iván duque dice que esta es
la cifra más alta en lo que va del siglo
21 es verdad sin embargo este aumento es
un efecto rebote porque el año pasado
para la misma época la economía estaba
bloqueada por la pandemia y es un efecto
que también se está viviendo en todo el
mundo no solamente en colombia'
ilusiones ninguna daniela hablemos ahora
de las grandes minoristas de eeuu que
presentaron resultados financieros allá
si están dando resultados así en el
segundo trimestre de este año las
grandes cadenas de retails repuntaron en
ventas a medida que los estadounidenses
volvieron a las tiendas a las escuelas y
a los lugares de trabajo pero están
aumentando las preocupaciones sobre si
ese comportamiento se mantendrá en los
próximos meses ya que los precios más
altos de alimentos y productos en
general están haciendo que los
compradores sean más conscientes del
gasto o marte que es la cadena minorista
más grande del mundo redujo sus
ganancias a estaban en un 34 por ciento
hasta los 4.200 millones de dólares pero
sus ingresos totales sí fueron más altos
y casi tocan los 140 mil millones de
dólares en el caso de hong tipo sus
utilidades subieron 11 por ciento otra
buena noticia también bueno las buenas y
otras no tan buenas pero hablemos ahora
de los indicadores pues fueron los datos
decepcionantes sobre ventas del sector
minorista justamente en eeuu los que
llevaron a pérdidas a wall street'
interrumpiendo una muy buena racha de
cinco días en europa los datos
optimistas de la zona euro ayudaron a
las bolsas a retomar las ganancias
después de haber caído a su nivel más
bajo en una semana y en américa latina
la bolsa de méxico sumó seis días de
ganancias esta vez gracias al buen
desempeño de américa móvil- dígame qué
tenemos cifra positiva para la cifra el
día bueno no es tan positiva son 300
millones de dólares por día que ha
costado a eeuu la guerra en afganistán
durante 20 años según un análisis de la
revista forbes y en todo lo excepcional
santiago muchas gracias daniel así son
los números y la economía es todo por el
momento aquí en france24 siga con
nosotros
[Música]